[Music]
oh
[Music]
japan rose to almost immediate cinematic
prominence with the one-two punch of
yasujiro ozu's 1953 tokyo story and
akira kusawa's 1954 7 samurai part of a
creatively fertile post-war period that
saw similar artistic strides in italy
france and sweden ozu's deeply human
drama and kurosawa's action genre big
bang are both certified fresh meaning
they've maintained a 75 after at least
40 critic reviews
that's the only ozu movie on our guide
to japanese certified fresh films while
kurosawa appears five more times with
rashaman ikiru throne of blood yoshimbo
and ron other directors featured in our
guide to certified fresh films produced
in japan include hirokazu coriada genre
icon takeshi ketano neon genesis
evangelion creator hidea akiano the
impossibly prolific takashi mikey and
yojiro takeda whose departures took home
the best foreign language film academy
award in 2008 a first for japan anime
has been one of japan's greatest
entertainment exports with hayao
miyazaki's films at the forefront other
prominent animation directors include
isau takahata makoto shinkai satoshi
kone and mamuro hasoda
[Music]
number 10 jiro dreams of sushi
revered sushi chef jiro ono strives for
perfection in his work while his eldest
son yoshikazu has trouble living up to
his father's legacy starring jiro ono
kevin iwashina and david gelb who also
directed the film critics say beautiful
thoughtful and engrossing giro dreams of
sushi should prove satisfying even for
film-goers who don't care for the
cuisine
[Music]
night
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
number nine shoplifters
on the margins of tokyo a dysfunctional
band of outsiders is united by fierce
loyalty and a penchant for petty theft
when the young sun is arrested secrets
are exposed that up end their tenuous
below the radar existence starring lily
frankie sakura andu maiu matsuoka and
directed by hirokazu korita critics say
understated yet ultimately deeply
affecting shoplifters adds another
powerful chapter to director hirokazu
karida's richly humanistic filmography
[Music]
[Music]
so you're right
oh
[Music]
number eight grave of the fireflies
a teenager is charged with the care of
his younger sister after an ally
firebombing during world war ii destroys
their home and kills their mother
starring j robert spencer wrote a crow
site amy jones and directed by isa o
takahata critics say an achingly sad
anti-war film grave of the fireflies is
one of studio ghibli's most profoundly
beautiful haunting works
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number seven tokyo story
the elderly shukishi and his wife tomy
take the long journey from their small
seaside village to visit their adult
children in tokyo their elder son koichi
a doctor and their daughter shigee a
hairdresser don't have much time to
spend with their aged parents and so it
falls to noriko the widow of their
younger son who was killed in the war to
keep her in-laws company starring chichu
ryu chi echo higashiyama setsukohara and
directed by yasujiru ozu critics say
tokyo story is a yasujiru ozu
masterpiece whose rewarding complexity
has lost none of its power more than
half a century on
[Music]
is
[Music]
oregano
[Music]
number six tampopo
two japanese milk truck drivers help a
restaurant owner learn how to cook great
noodles starring tutomu yamazaki nabuko
miyamoto ken watanabe and directed by
juzo itami critics say thanks to
director juzo itami's offbeat humor and
sharp satirical edge tampopo is a funny
sexy affectionate celebration of food
and its broad influence on japanese
culture
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
year old japanese office worker travels
to the countryside and reminisces about
her childhood in tokyo and what life
could have been starring daisy ridley
dev patel ashley eckstein and directed
by isao takahata critics say only
yesterday's long-delayed us debut fills
a frustrating gap for american ghibli
fans while offering further proof of the
studio's incredibly consistent
commitment to quality
city people see forests and woods and
streams and they're happy because they
think what they're seeing is nature
apart from back deep in the mountains
almost everything you see here is the
work of a farmer
that's so
sure of course it is
the river the dam
and those woods planted
and the stream doug
irrigation
it's not just the paddies and the fields
everything has been touched by man
our ancestors cleared this and
cultivated that
encouraged mushrooms berries wild garlic
really yeah
the sceneries come about by lucky
accident
as people have struggled with nature to
get what they needed to survive
so without people
this scenery wouldn't have been here
no it wouldn't have
to get what they need from nature
farmers have to do a lot of different
things to make sure that nature will
continue to provide forever
[Music]
number four still walking
12 years after their beloved eldest son
june pay drowned while saving a
stranger's life kyohei and toshiko
welcomed their surviving children home
for a family reunion younger son ryota
still feels that his parents resent that
he isn't the one who died his new wife
yukari is awkwardly meeting the rest of
the family for the first time daughter
chinami streams to fill the
uncomfortable pauses with forced cheer
starring hiroshi ebay you yoshio harada
and directed by hirokazu karida critics
say hirokazu karita's film may seem
modest at first but this family drama
casts a delicate entrancing spell
oh
my
number three drive my car
two years after his wife's unexpected
death yusuke kafuku a renowned staged
actor and director receives an offer to
direct a production of uncle vanya at a
theater festival in hiroshima there he
meets masaki watari a taciturn young
woman assigned by the festival to
chauffeur him in his beloved red saab
900. as the production premiere
approaches tensions mount amongst the
cast and crew not least between yusuke
and koji takasuki a handsome tv star who
shares an unwelcome connection to
yusuke's late wife forced to confront
painful truths raised from his past
yusuke begins with the help of a driver
to face the haunting mysteries his wife
left behind adapted from haruki murakami
short story riya's k hamaguchi's drive
my car is a haunting road movie
traveling a path of love loss acceptance
and peace starring hidey toshi nishijima
toko miura raycock hiroshima and
directed by riyas k hamaguchi critics
say drive by cars imposing runtime holds
a rich patiently engrossing drama that
reckons with self-acceptance and regret
um
foreign
mmm
[Music]
foreign
number two seven samurai
a samurai answers a village's request
for protection after he falls on hard
times the town needs protection from
bandits so the samurai gathers six
others to help him teach the people how
to defend themselves and the villagers
provide the soldiers with food a giant
battle occurs when 40 bandits attack the
village starring tashiro mafune takashi
shimura yoshio and naba and directed by
akira kurosawa critics say arguably
akira kurosawa's masterpiece 7th samurai
is an epic adventure classic with an
engrossing story memorable characters
and stunning action sequences that make
it one of the most influential films
ever made
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the twilight samurai
in 1860s japan samurai sebay lives in a
rural village with his mother and
daughters where he's stuck working as a
bookkeeper rather than a warrior
disillusioned by his position in society
and the death of his wife cebe finally
stirred from his malaise by the arrival
of tomoe a woman he loved as a child his
feelings for her are still strong but
the burdens of family career and social
standings could keep sebe from following
his desires starring hiroyuki sonata rye
miyazawa nj kobayashi and directed by
yoshi yamada critics say samurai epic as
a touching drama
okay
oh
oh
your name
a teenage boy and girl embark on a quest
to meet each other for the first time
after they magically swap bodies
starring ryonosuke kamiki monet kami
shiraishi rio narita and directed by
makoto shinkai critics say as
beautifully animated as it is
emotionally satisfying your name adds
another outstanding chapter to writer
director makoto shinkai's filmography
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
spirited away
ten-year-old chihiro moves with their
parents to a new home in a japanese
countryside after taking a wrong turn
down a wooded path chihiro and her
parents discover an amusement park with
a stall containing an assortment of food
to her surprise chihiro's parents begin
eating and then transform into pigs in
this supernatural realm chihiro
encounters a host of characters and
endures labor in a bath house for
spirits awaiting a reunion with her
parents starring rumi hiragi miyu irino
marie natsuki and directed by hayao
miyazaki critics say spirited away is a
dazzling enchanting and gorgeously drawn
fairy tale that will leave viewers a
little more curious and fascinated by
the world around them
[Music]
this is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and finally number one the tale of the
princess kaguya
a tiny nymph found inside a bamboo stock
grows into a beautiful and desirable
young woman who orders her suitors to
prove their love by completing a series
of near impossible tasks starring aki
asakura kangokora takeochi and directed
by iso takahata critics say boasting
narrative depth frank honesty and
exquisite visual beauty the tale of the
princess kaguya is a modern animated
treasure with timeless appeal
[Music]
and friends that about does it for us be
sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i'm your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you